[Music]
police forces around the world
have been increasingly investing
in transforming their vehicle fleet into
electric
yay are they getting teslas they're
getting um
elec they don't say exactly zero mission
vehicles
better not be charging at the tesla
stations
because then they're gonna they're gonna
take a ball space need to go back to
their station and charge their own [ __ ]
back to your station nissan leaps mostly
oh what oh that's not the first that's
not a pursuit car at all [ __ ] no you're
just gonna you're wrong
you're dead wrong you can't even catch a
jaywalker on that card what's your top
speed
that's maybe that's like a parking
ticket violation cop that's how i know
this show is just talking out of its ass
because the facts are police are having
all kinds of problems uh trying to chase
down criminals with these cars
so yeah you guys were right why don't
they just go full tesla or something huh
cause teslas are expensive
what does the leaf look like i can't
play into the monopoly yeah nissan leaf
is just like a a really here i'll pull
one up just a econo box that's all
electric but like they're actually like
a scion they're actually trying to
pursue criminals
and they're not able to keep that's not
what i mean this is yeah for
administrative [ __ ] sure or like yeah
put writing tickets or whatever sure but
like not for doing anything serious like
meter made [ __ ] that car is kind of sexy
though bro damn dude
universe
picture like this right not moving
that's what it's like when cops are in
it too
i wonder if they did the actual math on
like how much money they'd be saving
[ __ ] now because uh i know i know for a
fact a lot of cops like when they're
eating lunch it's their policy to keep
the car running
so once they get in the car like if they
get the patrol car if they go eat lunch
if they're like
even if they're pumping gas or they
don't get water or whatever the car is
pumping gas too yeah oh [ __ ] i know you
could do that no that's that's what my
friends tell me they're like dude it's
been a lot that to turn off your gas
when you pump gas because you don't have
to
you could just leave it running because
i thought they also have like gangster
ass maintenance and tuning for their
cars they do they do because they're
like they're pretty much sports cars but
um the fact that they just leave it
running all the time i'm sure like you
probably burn through a lot of gasoline
right so they also gotta be ready to go
well the horns and sirens apparently are
really draining on the battery
is that actually yeah actually yeah
actually yeah so they're like baby [ __ ]
we gotta go charge them like every beep
is a mile
yeah so they they're struggling to fight
crime due to the evs uh as they're
running out of power oh my hilarious
yeah well they also chose a shitty
[ __ ] evie
they they really chose that the nissan
leaf what uh what departments
oh these are this is all around the uk
and
gloucester the gloucester constabulary
because i was like in america it's gonna
be americans if i saw yeah dude if you
okay so they say your community crime
you saw like dude [ __ ] roll up in a
leaf would you run for it i would
[ __ ] smash the police car with my car
i'll just run straight into it you would
crush it yeah that had to be yeah i was
like there's no because americans you
have to go with the american car i feel
like all the other cops though have the
cutest cars and they're very
non-threatening yeah like oh yeah all
the cops i mean maybe like in africa is
a little bit different because they got
like [ __ ] straight up like jeeps and
[ __ ] and it looks crazy as mexico is
pretty wild as well mexico is pretty
cool but i would say japan got the
cutest cop cars man they got like they
got like they got they got yeah they got
mini like like mini coopers going around
yeah that's why they got like those
plastic shields and they don't use guns
at all and they can suppress people
still and it makes sense so cute they
have a baton so they hit you over dude i
saw how they take down people though
it's [ __ ] wild dog
yeah so they use judo techniques right
they'll be like so there was like this
six foot big ass [ __ ] like wrestle
looking tourist he was junk as [ __ ] he
was knocking people out right and then
you see a swarm of japanese ants just
[ __ ] in police uniforms right and
geese like little japanese
police black and white police and then
they just they just surround this dude
and then you see one guy coming up to
him and distracting him and then it's
like hella organized like they come in
this one guy grab some [ __ ] judo
throws them and as soon as he gets them
on the ground like they all [ __ ] dog
pile on them like football players huh
yeah and the crusher did basically
it's crazy
no guns man
just dog piling uh so the uk government
critics are saying that the uk
government has announced a ban on the
sales of new fossil fuel powered
vehicles by 2030 but they're kind of
putting the car before the horse and not
really checking this [ __ ] out very well
um so that's why the critics are alive
they're getting out ran on foot by
criminals
just imagine that you're in the year
2029 they have a huge huge [ __ ]
numbers for like gas emission vehicles
and stuff like that carbon vehicles
everyone tries to like hoard and buy as
many of the old diesel cars as possible
before they can't sell them anymore well
i think the cops are counting on you
know the population who are you know who
are using electric vehicles also to run
will also be a little bit [ __ ] too so
it's kind of fair it's like way more so
as long as everyone's slow and running
out of power okay so their
high speed pursuits would be 30 miles
per hour now instead of like way more
safe 100 something or it's just one of
those things where it's like like you
guys are talking about fighting they
because they have electric vehicles they
have really really strong torque right
so that means that if they're going to
get into some sort of change a leaf
though not only maybe they just got to
be able to catch it in the first minute
other than that you're going to lose
that you're thinking about being in a
tesla dude i don't think the leaf has
that kind of [ __ ] i want to see a tesla
cop car that would be interesting man
tesla's gold cyber truck super fast
mythical cyber truck that's never coming
out that one yeah but then you could
just smash into [ __ ] because
it's like full steel i don't know man
threw that baseball at it uk streets
it's gonna like hit the buildings
by 2030 um the buildings are going to be
much more separated oh i understand yeah
but from natural like
global warming you know tesla has a uh
like a kill switch where um because
obviously everything that works on an
electrical
network that
is also connected to like the internet
and stuff like that like uh under
whatever threat where some mass hack
should take place and they can hack in
and control every car every car they
have a kill switch
that makes it so that their every car
gets disconnected from the network at
the same time and then everybody's
manually operating that's why i use a
vpn with my tesla that's pretty cool do
you know what's uh what's a toodaloo
with that
uh
onstars like that too hon star sounds
like an ancient dinosaur
technically all these car brands that
have it like every car like ford has
their own version toyota has their own
version they all have their own network
team well i'm just saying in terms of
the difference between like that is
regardless of the network it's like your
car's still gonna run on gas that's why
i only buy cars pre-1990 because i don't
want the government trying to shut down
my car when i'm in a high speed pursuit
yeah it's nice to come you're out there
that's that that's a nice new to go into
90 tacoma what are you talking about
ryan that's 1989.
wow they got crazy tekken 1989 put down
the pre-order in 1989
just like he put down the pre-order for
the cyber truck
that is kind of like when you're in you
know you ever see you ever got a buddy
who's got like an old car like bart's
favorite cars like 1967
chevelle
but then they rip out all the insides
and they like put all the new [ __ ] in
there
it's like like omaze yeah it's like this
isn't that [ __ ]
right oh maybe like here's this classic
oh it drives like [ __ ] isn't that power
steering like
that's the fun of it that's the
character
that's the charm i mean that's
eventually what i'm gonna do when i roll
the window down yeah
i found a when i was shopping around for
cars i found a civic that someone had a
2000 civic that someone had gutted and
put 2015 civic intern like bull terrier
into like a full 2015 civic interior
honda civic lx interior that's not even
cool yeah or like the base like the si
basically so i was like why would
someone do this and they wanted like 13
grand but i was like yeah [ __ ] up wow
that's a good deal dude i would buy that
in a heartbeat but was it like a rice
rocket like oh yeah i mean it was like
riced out but it was like it was a it
was a civic that i wanted like the 2000
civics are cool but they had taken like
a modern interior and put it into it
like what now it has airbags yeah dude
weirdly similar thing but a different
area my brother was trying to sell
mother brother's trying to sell his
house
and his mom-in-law has too many opinions
about show like all kinds of [ __ ] and
she thinks she knows [ __ ] everything
and she's like let me tell you
big hot trend right now you paint the
kitchen teal
and he's like what the [ __ ] oh he's like
really and then because he doesn't
[ __ ] know
she's like she's like yeah you painted
teal and he's like all right like he's
gonna sell it easier yeah because it's
way easier because it's like hot right
now everyone's buying teal kitchens and
[ __ ] not kidding by the way it sounds
like a joke it's not so he goes ahead
and has it painted because he's already
getting the pants he's like fine here
dude
and then they do it and nobody wants to
buy his [ __ ] house because of the
teal kitchen
they're like it would have been perfect
but the [ __ ] teal it's like such a
stark choice why would you pick that and
he's like ah my mom thought it was a hot
thing going on she saw some hdtv show
thinks everyone's doing it
like chip and joanna gaines did it one
time so now everyone's gonna [ __ ] do
it
so short long story short he had he had
her she actually offered to pay because
he was like yo everyone's saying as [ __ ]
everybody's saying what an oddly
responsible choice for someone with a
weird opponent and not kidding he paint
he paints it and he sells it within like
nine days oh no way he just paints it
back to what like white or something
yeah it was like normal the person buys
it is like dang i would have paid more
if it was teal
it was nothing it was like not even a
grand dude that's what i'm saying isn't
it so weird that like
what's holding up the sale of like
thousands of dollars is like
500 that's what i learned like in home
buying dude so many people have no
imagination that they just want a house
like oh the wall it's like you could
[ __ ] paint that [ __ ] you want turkey
dude i want a turkey that's it that's
the term yeah we're moving right away
joe i guess
he's not buying it joe's skeptical joe
only buys really old cars
my next one is a datsun diesel yeah
exactly older and older and older and
older he's gonna start cranking cranking
it to start it oh
and if he even stops at the stop sign he
breaks his [ __ ] nose on the dashboard
i wouldn't make these so sharp and metal
no although my truck feels like i'm
driving a tractor that's nice
inside the windows you don't get that
kind of uh visual radius anymore no
because the a-pillars got to be strong
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you